welcome back to 8701
so now um after we introduced um
the weak interaction um and the feynman
rules four week interaction we can now
look at
the case of neurons and in this case the
decay of a pion
decay of the pion is specifically
interesting and we discussed the decay
of the prion before
when it came to the discussion of
helicity states now let's look at this
again
with the information we have and what we
learned
now if you look at the pi and decay the
two leading
two of three leading decay modes are
given here the one is where the pion in
this case a
negatively charged fire decays into an
entry electron neutrino
and an electron or via the w
in a muon and an antimur neutrino
if you look at this in the rest frame of
the pion
we can see that the neutrino and the
lepton charged lepton are produced back
to back
now the spin of the pion is zero which
means that
the out in opposite direction outgoing
leptons have to have the same velocity
states
since the neutrino is massless the
anti-neutrino is massless
the anti-neutrino is produced
right-handed
it's always right-handed the carrier
state of the neutrino
and the eliciting state of the neutrino
are essentially the same because they
are massless
meaning the projection of the sphenoid
um
is basically the same as the projection
of the
spin in on the momentum direction
all right but the charged lepton is
massive if the charge laptop would be
massless
um the decay would not be allowed there
would not be
a right-handed helicity state for
[Music]
now this causes quite some confusion and
i've seen uh even in this course some
students being confused by this
um i can write the um
let's say right-handed charge lepton and
decomposes
as right-handed helicity state so this
is let's say the
right-handed elicity state
and i can decompose this through the
chiral states
the right-handed and the left
left-handed
and we have seen in previous in the
previous lectures that only the
left-handed component
participates now you can also see from
this equation here
that if the momentum and energy would be
the same as that it's the case for mass
particle this would be zero this would
be one
this would be one and therefore this
right-handed helicity state would be the
same essay
as the chiral state and it wouldn't be
coupling
to the weak interaction well let's erase
this really quickly because we want to
actually
look at this decay
and so now we have all the tools to get
almost all the tools together to
calculate this
um the decay rates or the ratio of decay
rates
and you want to do this in the pi and
rest frame so the momentum are given the
moment are given here
see that the pi momentum is zero the
formamental energy is equal to the mass
for the charged lepton and for the
neutrino just produced in an
opposite direction so neutrino in this
case goes into negative z direction
then we can write the electronic current
as we have just seen in the previous
lecture you see this one minus gamma 5
term here
um good and i could have just called
this
left that left handed here and put this
into the definition of the spinner
fine when we put a real spinner this
comes out immediately the right
when immediately you have to keep this
in mind
the matrix element then is a little bit
more complicated here's an
additional so you see the the current
here again
see the propagator and i
went into the low energy approximation
here you see that
instead of having a q q square minus m
square i'm just keeping the n square
component of this
and then i have this case part here for
the current for the ion current
here and i simply parametrize my missing
understanding or missing ability to
calculate non-perturbative qcd
with the form factor so i introduce this
form factor for pi
this is not the important part of the
discussion we just keep track of this
here
all right we can calculate this matrix
element fine
we then have to be explicit about the
sphenos we are using and we use
the momentum as defined above so this
step here i'm not doing explicitly if
you want
you can go to thomson
thompson and read in chapter
11 he gives quite some detail on this
all right um so moving on um there's one
extra thing when we try
to calculate the spin average
matrix element um we find that we don't
have to do any work because
there's been sphero says there's only
one state contributing so we
you know don't have to do any work we
just have to square the matrix element
we find this as a solution here and
there's an additional factor we haven't
introduced yet
this is the fermi coupling again this is
um
comes out in the low energy um
approximation
and g fermi is simply defined over
the coupling to the w over the w
mass squared as shown here all right
again this is just a factor which is not
relevant to the discussion at this
point um but we can then using
um from his golden rule calculates the
partial decay bits
of the pion decay
okay so we just put in the matrix
element here
and we replace the momentum with the
energy
um being equal to the mass of the pion
and voila we get this as an answer for
the partial
cables okay if you do not want to know
some experimental
information like the partial decay bits
of the pie uncharged pi and
to electrons over the muon you want to
know what this factor is
we immediately can do this we don't need
to know any of the details
as g fermi as a structure function of
the ion
all of those vectors cancel out and what
is left here
are the parameters of the electron mass
the neuron mass and the ion mass
and if you just use
values like this the mass of the neuron
will 205 mev
and the mass of the pion equal 240
mav you find 10 to the minus 4
as values uh as a value for this ratio
of partial indicators
and you see where this comes from this
basically comes from the fact that the
electron mass is much much smaller than
the mass
of the mirror and it's actually you can
explain this
by the fact that a right-handed helicity
state formula
can have a much larger contribution
of the left-handed chiral state of a
neuron
why this is not possible or this
component is much
smaller for the lighter electron and
again
only the left-handed component of the
charged leptons
of the charged lepton contributes to the
weak interaction